- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians.
Welcome to the English parts of speech.
We're gonna begin with the noun,
the lovely wonderful noun,
your friend and mine.
They're mostly what you're
gonna encounter in sentences.
Most sentences in English
contain at least one noun
or a pronoun, but we'll
get to pronouns later.
A noun is basically anything.
And I know that's not an
especially helpful definition,
but we'll get more specific in a minute.
A noun is basically anything at all.
Now the way this is taught
in traditional grammar
is to say that a noun is
a person, place or thing,
which is fine, I think we can
make that a little bit sharper
and expand that out by
saying that they are,
that nouns are people or living things,
places,
things, or ideas.
I think ideas is the one
that usually gets left out.
So nouns can be people,
places, things and ideas.
Let's put that in action.
So, this is Raul.
He is from Argentina.
He is a penguin.
Raul has big dreams.
Now, okay.
So, I wanna take these three sentences
and find the noun in them using the test.
So the test is, is it a person
or a living thing, a place,
a thing, or an idea?
And if it's any of those things,
then it falls into the
category of words in English
which we call nouns.
So, sentence number one.
This is Raul.
What is Raul?
Well, Raul is a person or a living thing
so we're just gonna say person so noun.
Next sentence.
He is from Argentina.
Now Argentina happens to be a place
so therefore, it is also a noun.
It's a kind of noun called a proper noun,
just like Raul is but
we'll get to that later.
So, Argentina is a noun.
Argentina incidentally is a country
and the word country is also a noun
because it is a thing.
So, sentence the third.
He is a penguin.
Now, a penguin is a
living being or a thing
so we can say oh yes, penguin,
that is a noun as well.
So, you've noticed I'm
not circling he or this.
These words are pronouns,
relative pronouns,
and they can sometimes behave like nouns,
but I wouldn't call them nouns.
That'll just get confusing.
So, these are pronouns and
we'll get to them later.
Sentence number four.
Raul has big dreams.
So, here we have Raul again.
We know from the first sentence
that it's a person's name.
So, we're just gonna say
this is also a noun again.
And dreams.
Now, dreams isn't a person, a place.
It's a thing, sure.
The reason I put in idea
as a fourth category is
to get it stuff that you can't pick up.
Like for example, so dream,
yes, dream is a noun.
Dream is maybe a little tangible
'cause it's something you can imagine,
but the idea of like a word like bigness.
Or if you prefer, you know, size.
The size of Raul's
plumage was astonishing.
Look at that gorgeous plumage.
It's a little penguin mohawk.
(high-pitched murmurs)
The size of Raul's plumage was astounding.
Now in that sentence, size is a noun,
but it's not a physical thing,
it's not a person, it's not a place,
it's not something you can pick up.
It's an idea.
So, that's why I include
this fourth category.
So, if you're trying to figure out
whether or not a word is a noun,
just apply this test.
Ask yourself, is it a person, a place,
a thing, or an idea?
And you, my friend, will be golden.
You can learn anything.
David out.